GARY GENSLER: Welcome
back to Fintech:
Shaping the Financial World.
This is our last time together.
And so we're going to
try to summarize up
what this semester's been and
some thoughts going forward
as all of you go
forth, and try to think
about this intersection
of technology and finance.
And again, we've taught it
from that point of view,
not necessarily just
about startups, but how
technology and
finance come together
in the world of finance.
And it's been shaping it,
really, for centuries.
But the dominant sort of themes
that we've been talking about
is the new technologies that,
in the last five to 15 years,
have really been
transforming finance
around artificial
intelligence and machine
learning, natural
language processing,
having dramatic changes, but
also open API and the access
to data through technological
connections, sometimes done
by commerce, sometimes the
official sector has sort of
moved and pressed against it.
And then, of course, data,
and all the different forms
of alternative data, some off
of just traditional means,
like whether we pay our rent on
time, some from social media.
And then when we
looked at insurtech,
that I know really
lifted the class up,
this look at
insurance and finance,
but then also telematics,
meaning all the data
that a car brings
on us, or wearables,
if we wear a Fitbit or
a watch or something,
or the Internet of Things.
And then we've talked even
about some technologies that
haven't yet come into
the technology stack,
like blockchain
technology, and will it?
It's already been a
catalyst for change,
but will it sort of come in and
dramatically change finance.
So as we normally do, if we can
try to be part of the community
and have our videos on, I
still see some with it off.
I know at 12 lectures in,
and it's early morning.
But I think if we can just
try to close out together
with our videos on, and
if you have questions,
raising the little
Zoom blue hand
or going into the chat room.
And Romain is going
to take a close look
and try to have a dialogue here.
I do have some slides to put up.
I'm still the same faculty
member of the other 11 classes,
but let me share some
slides and we'll get going.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about this finance
technology stack and how I see
these technologies fitting in,
the actors again, and then
a review of the key areas,
machine learning, open
API, credit scoring,
alternative data,
and the question
marks around
blockchain technology.
And then a quick sector review,
and bringing those all together
and wrapping it up
The study questions was
really about what is fintech?
And so I don't know if everybody
just wants to have an easy,
hit the ball out
of the park moment.
But to you all, what is
fintech and how might it
shape the future?
ROMAIN: This is the last class
and your last opportunity
to shine, guys.
GARY GENSLER: Don't you love how
Romain sort of pulls it all out
of you so readily, easily?
ROMAIN: This is the last class.
Danielle, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The
application of technology
to financial services,
and how might
it shape the future of money
and finance in unlimited ways.
GARY GENSLER: An optimist.
I like that about you, Dani.
Unlimited ways.
So do you think we'll
have banks in the future?
Let's go right to
the heart of it.
Will we have commercial
banks in the future?
AUDIENCE: I think yes.
I think it's hard to
dislodge institutions
with that much inertia.
But they may not look
the way they look.
They may get
slightly more agile,
adapt, and have
digital currency.
They might pull in some
of the fintech disruptors.
So yes, we'll have
commercial banks,
but they may not look
precisely like they do today.
GARY GENSLER: I, too, think that
we'll have commercial banks.
And I think it's more
than just inertia.
I think that there's certain
network effects that we've
seen for centuries about
bringing depositors
and borrowers together and
forming that intersection, sort
of like a neck of an
hourglass, but forming
that intersection where the
grains of sand, money and risk,
flow between depositors who
have money but want to save it,
and borrowers who
want to borrow it,
and the commercial banks
bring that together.
Peer to peer lending
has been around now
for some 15 years, this
concept that we don't need
an intermediary in the middle.
And then maybe
borrowers and lenders
can come together on
a technology platform.
And it's had some success,
not just here in the US,
but it started in Europe.
It's been here in the US.
It's been in China with great
numbers and some challenges
as well.
But I think what we've seen
is, by and large, we still
have some centralized
marketplaces that
come together.
Now that's not the only reason
I think commercial banking will
be around, but I think there
are significant network
effects pulling at the center.
How do you best assess the
viability of a fintech project?
ROMAIN: Carlos, you like
to take a stab at that?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I think there's
a couple elements.
One is to what degree
is it an improvement
relative to a
traditional product?
How much more convenient
is it for users?
And how much more
accessible is it?
I think those are
important factors.
Of course, there's a
financial liability.
You have to look at the actual
economics of the product
to see whether or not
it's scalable, above all,
and whether it makes sense
to have it at a large degree.
And then ultimately,
I think we've
seen, especially
the last five years,
whether fintech
companies can actually
become publicly owned companies,
how they handle themselves
in the stock market, et cetera.
So I think there's been several
phases to the evolution,
and it's continuing.
GARY GENSLER: So very
helpful, in part.
So first Carlos said
fundamentally, you have
to have a value proposition.
I'm using my words, but
sort of translating it,
if that's all right, Carlos.
So what pain points
are you addressing?
What gap in the current
system of finance?
And it might be about user
interface and user experience.
And as mobile phones
came along, as we
moved from online banking
and online trading
to mobile banking and
mobile trading that,
creates opportunities.
Many of those opportunities
have already happened.
They're not all done, but
many of those opportunities
of that transition from bricks
and mortar to the internet,
to mobile phones, have happened.
But they create opportunities
of user experience and user
interface.
But it has to address some
pain point, do something
quicker, cheaper, better.
It's an old saw in
terms of strategy.
But then Carlos is
also saying we need
to have financial viability.
At some point in
time, you have to be
able to build a model where
revenues are more than costs.
A lot of these startups are
looking for that sweet spot,
that sort of nirvana
moment when you
build a platform, where platform
economics and the network
effects take off.
But Carlos said you
still have to have
some financial viability
at some point in time.
I think there was
another hand up, Romain.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think to kind
of built on Carlos's point,
another thing that might
make or break a product
is potential for fraud
or the risk profile
increase on a specific area.
One thing we were kind of
talking about as a group
was alternative scoring,
and that's something
that we're just
not sure if we're
hot on or not just
because is taking
alternative data actually going
to increase or reduce risks
looking forward.
GARY GENSLER: So
Michael, I think
what you're saying
is you still have
to live within
regulatory constraints
and social constraints in terms
of there's normative behavior,
and this is a highly regulated
field, and for good reason.
We're dealing with
trust, and trust
is at the center of finance.
We're also dealing with other
people's money and livelihood
and savings and investments.
And so there's
investor protection,
there's consumer protection, and
in terms of alternative data,
the basic tenets
around the globe
that when you extend credit
or offer somebody insurance,
it should be done
fairly and unbiased.
And so how do we ensure that
the use of alternative data
still stays within those social
and legal norms about offering
credit and insurance in
an unbiased and fair way.
I think that's what you
were chatting about.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, kind of.
I was just thinking about, also,
the lack of adoption crypto.
It's like, if it's just
going to sort of attract
scammers and
fraudulent activity,
the technology is going to
have a hard time being adopted.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
Right.
So of course we want to protect
against fraud in the capital
markets.
We also want to protect
against manipulation
and ensure investment
protection.
And we've seen,
particularly in some fields
like cryptocurrencies,
that they're
rife with fraud and manipulation
and sort of quick buck artists,
frankly, around the globe.
And so to ensure that
any long-term viability
of a project, real
viability comes
with investor protection,
consumer protection norms,
as well as norms about fairness,
inclusiveness, explainability,
and the like.
In most nations, these are
embedded in various regulations
and laws.
So standing up a new
effort, whether it's inside
of an incumbent, inside
a big tech, or a startup,
you've got to look at
the regulatory context.
But Michael's
pointing out, also,
you've got to go
a little further
and make sure that
you're really serving
your public and your community.
And then the last question
is, I hope that we've
met the goals of the class.
But I do ask you today and over
the next few weeks, write me.
Write me at
gensler@mit.edu and tell me
what we could do better.
This the first year
we've stood this up.
This class is also going
to be shown publicly
in MIT'S OpenCourseWare.
So those of you that might
be watching this publicly,
write me and tell me what we can
do in this class going forward
and how we can make
it a better product.
I'm kind of curious
whether it's made
some folks more bullish or
more bearish on fintech,
and I'm going to ask this
at the end of class as well,
but if there's anybody who
wants to chat now, Romain?
Anybody want to take the bullish
side or the bearish side?
ROMAIN: Danielle
has her hand up.
AUDIENCE: I think it depends
on which hat I have on,
if I'm an investor
or entrepreneur.
The class has made
me more bullish.
Lots of opportunities out there.
If I have my citizen hat on,
I think I net out at bearish,
not so much on the industry,
but more on its impact for me.
I'm certainly thrilled
at the ability
to access different forms
of payment and lending.
But ultimately, I think
the long-term costs
in terms of the data
these companies will
have on me, and the
just immense role
and control over my life,
I net out at bearish.
And then if I'm
the government, I'm
probably netting out at
bearish as well because this
is going to mean a gnarly
set of regulations and laws
to navigate that means
a lot more work for me.
GARY GENSLER: Very interesting,
very nuanced answer.
I see some other hands up.
ROMAIN: Celi?
GARY GENSLER: Maybe you've
got your mute on still.
ROMAIN: Yes, we can't hear you.
OK.
Then let's move on to Lamide.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm more bullish.
For me one of the
interesting trends
I see is serving
the underserved,
whether that's in crypto trying
to serve the population that
doesn't have to be VC, or
whether it's in insurance.
you have all these
trends where people
are getting more nuanced
products to really target
populations that
are underserved.
And all these different kind
of new innovations around that
inspire me.
GARY GENSLER: So we've
got bullish as an investor
from Dani.
We've got bullish for economic
inclusion and product inclusion
just now from Lamide.
But there were some
bearishness from Dani
on data and the industry
knowing so much more about us.
Was there anybody else,
Romain, that wanted to add in?
ROMAIN: Maybe Celi, if her
microphone works, and Luke.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
And then we'll move on.
We'll take Luke and Celi.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
My internet connection's poor.
But I think I'd like to echo--
I missed part of Lamide's but my
thing was financial inclusion.
So really entering,
I think, also, it's
in the benefit of
the government, too.
I know that there are
some concerns there,
but I think if you're
thinking about it
from an economic
growth perspective,
there's a lot of
opportunity through fintech
that would end up really
benefit the entire economy.
So I think that there's the
argument for the government
to have interest and to be
a more bullish approach as
well, even though there
are risks involved.
GARY GENSLER: So you
accept a little bit
what Dani was saying
that for the government,
the official sector, some of the
challenges, to use her words,
were gnarly.
But though there's challenges,
you think to the extent
that it promotes inclusion
and economic activity,
that innovation is a net
good, and competition,
if I can insert something.
What fintech does is it
provides an opportunity
both for incumbents and
startups and big competitors
like big tech to start to
bring competitive challenges.
We saw this in China
when Ally Pay and WeChat
Pay bring economic challenges
to the banking sector
and now dominate the
retail payment space.
But for a while, all
of that inclusion
creates economic opportunity.
I say for a while because
at some point in time,
then they too become
a bit of an oligopoly.
And they can charge, over
time, economic rents.
But that has certainly
brought a lot of inclusion,
a lot of growth, a lot
of economic opportunity
to underserved
populations, in that case,
in China and elsewhere in Asia.
We've also seen that
across the US and in Europe
with competition from challenger
banks and neo banks and payment
companies, long ago, like PayPal
started 20 years ago, or more
recently, by many of the payment
innovators in this space,
whether they're data
aggregators or direct payment
solutions like Toast in
the restaurant business.
But as Dani said
also, the Plaids,
which are the data aggregators,
or even the Credit Karmas
giving us free access
to our credit reports,
or Robin Hood giving
us free access
to trading online
brokerage, also
then are collecting
significant amount of data.
And whether they're
commercializing that data
in ways we understand,
appreciate, and want,
Dani is sort of
raising that makes her
a little uncomfortable as well.
And I think we were going
to close it out with Luke.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
bullish in the long term
in the sense that two
conditions are met,
the convenience and then
technology acceptance in terms
of blockchain.
You teach blockchain and money.
And if people accept blockchain
as technology as core
to fintech, it has
a lot of potentials.
If not, this is nothing more
than making any status quo
industry more convenient
and more accessible.
So little bearish.
GARY GENSLER: So
you're bullish, and one
of the reasons you're bullish
is you feel the blockchain
technology is a positive.
And is that positive
because you feel
it's pushing at the
side of central banks,
pushing at the side of
central payment processors
and the rest of finance,
which I would share that view.
I think it's a catalyst.
And it's part of why we've
seen a lot of innovation.
Even our US Federal
Reserve, who was thinking
about doing 24 hour a day, seven
days a week payment systems,
is rolling out something
called Fed Now.
I think that's in part because
of this catalyst for change.
But do you also think that it
will be a mainstream product
offering, and that
blockchain technology will
roll into what I call the
technology stack in finance?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
believe in evolution,
so in 10 years or whatever
years that may take,
this is indeed the
best technology
if everyone accepts it.
So I don't see why not.
However, it will take
a tremendous amount
of time and energy and
effort for everyone
to accept it and understand it.
Either it takes a
crisis or it takes
governmental intervention.
GARY GENSLER: You may be right.
I still haven't been convinced,
but you may be right.
I'm sort of a
middle of the road.
I'm neither a minimalist
or a maximalist
on blockchain technology.
But it hasn't yet because
of the dominant challenges
of governance.
How do you have multiple
parties sharing a ledger?
And these issues of
governance are not new.
They're just in this context
of blockchain technology.
But the opportunity to have a
new data structure, a shared
data structure amongst
multiple parties,
I think you're probably right,
will come into use somewhere.
The question is how
broadly because you
have at the center a really--
Dani used the word
gnarly, but maybe
if I use that here, gnarly
set of governance issues,
how you have a shared data
structure, a shared ledger.
And then, of course,
in cryptocurrencies
is another set of challenges.
Is a private sector
currency needed?
Well, if fiat currencies
are well managed,
if monetary policy
and fiscal policies
are well managed, probably not.
But then again, the history of
nations, the history of finance
and money of 200 countries,
there tends to be one to three
at any given time that
aren't managing their fiat
currencies well.
So there you have it.
AUDIENCE: One last notice.
Only when governments' interest
aligns with the blockchain,
because fiat currency's
centralized and blockchain is
decentralized, would we have a
wide acceptance of blockchain,
correct?
GARY GENSLER:
That's a good point,
that the sovereign
currency is probably here
unless there's
some collaboration
between the central authorities
and the use of that technology
is your point.
So we're going to
dive in a little bit.
And just sort of
summarizing, I talk
about the technology stack.
And the cloud,
mobile, the internet
were important parts that were
added to the finance technology
stack, really, from the
1990s all the way till now.
And if you look at
big finance, all
using the internet, of
course, from the late '90s,
and into the naughts,
all pretty much
rolling out mobile applications,
particularly in the last 10
years, often because of the
pressures from startups.
Not so much all have
rolled in the cloud.
And many big finance
companies are still having
their centralized
data structures.
But more and more
are using the cloud.
What's important
about the cloud,
though, is that it gives
startups a real chance
to sort of rent versus bill.
So you don't have to build
your own data structure,
put it in Microsoft Azure,
put it in an Amazon AWS,
put it in [INAUDIBLE]
equivalents and so forth.
So those were all earlier
technologies fully
in the finance technology stack.
But we've talked a lot
about in this class machine
learning, natural
language processing,
the critical pieces,
really, in the last call it
seven to 10 years, that
computational power
and the ability to analyze
data and extract correlations.
And what machine learning
at its core does best,
it's remarkable at extracting
correlations, pattern
recognition, if you wish.
And that pattern
recognition on data
has started to really be
important in this field.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about it.
But it's also access to
data and digital interfaces
through open application
program interfaces, or API.
And you could have machine
learning and natural language
processing without
open API, but open API
is a really important
piece of this,
particularly as startups
try to get into this space.
And as we talked
about, some of that's
because the official sector
says, thou shall do this.
Some of it is technologically
facilitated by companies
that provided that access.
And then many of the incumbents
wanted to provide it as well.
And then, of course,
there's a whole bunch
of things that have been
in the technology stack
for decades or centuries.
We took those as givens.
And I think at some
point, when this course is
taught in the 2030s,
machine learning
will just be taken as a given.
Open API will be a
given, and there'll
be new technologies beyond that.
Now we talked about one
that's really in insurance.
And I kid the class a
little bit because I
know the interest has been more
in payments and in challenger
banks and neo banks.
But why I find insurance
so interesting is it's
starting to layer a new
technology into the technology
stack.
We don't see this as much in the
challenger banks and in credit.
But sensor data, telematics
in the automobiles,
wearables and the like.
All that remarkable amount of
data to assess and underwrite
insurance risk, whether
it's on an automobile,
whether it's on
a home, will that
come into the technology
stack of banks and credit card
companies?
We haven't yet seen it.
But other than sort of social
norms and regulatory reasons,
why wouldn't we see that wealth
of data from your automobile,
from your wearables, from
Internet of Things sensors
wouldn't start to
influence, and one
might say infiltrate, into
how credit decisions are
made, again, within the
regulatory construct
and so forth.
So one of the reasons why I
find insurance so fascinating,
because there's sort
of another technology
that they're starting
to use to collect data.
Really important.
And then lastly,
we've talked a lot
about blockchain technology.
I teach it as well.
I find it a fascinating area.
But just as that back
and forth with Luke,
I put question marks.
Will it come into that
full technology stack?
It's most definitely been
a catalyst for change.
It's pushing at the
edges of finance.
It's starting to make each
institution, whether it's
JP Morgan thinking
about a new way
to do payments with
something called JP Morgan
Coin, or a whole collection
of incumbent banks
around a project called Finality
or utility settlement coin.
We have, of course,
seen how Facebook
caught a great deal of
attention in 2019 and 2020
with their Facebook
Libra project,
a consortium to roll out
a new global currency,
both multi-basket
and single currency.
So incumbents in big tech are
taking very close look at this.
And then you have the
Central Bank of China,
People's Bank of
China doing something
called a digital currency
electronic payments program.
It's not using
blockchain technology.
But for sure it's inspired
by cryptocurrencies.
It's for sure put a higher
emphasis for all central banks
around the globe to consider
what's called central bank
digital currencies.
So I put some question marks
because we know it's already
been a catalyst for change,
but will it actually
be incorporated in
the technology stack?
Romain, any questions?
ROMAIN: Let's wait
just another second.
Yes, Hassan.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just have a question.
Now at the beginning
of the slide,
you said internet,
mobile, and the cloud.
What do you mean exactly?
I mean, did it move
from internet to cloud,
or is is just like
a new technology?
What do you mean?
GARY GENSLER: I'm sure-- because
your voice is fading out--
are you asking whether I think
these are new technologies?
I think they were new
when they rolled out
the internet fundamentally
in the mid- to late '90s
for most of finance
had to take notice.
But I assure you, having
lived it, in the early '90s,
the internet was not in
the technology stack,
meaning most of big finance
and startups of the time
didn't use it.
But many of the startups
by the late '90s had to.
Amazon started in 1995, and they
embedded the internet in it.
Of course, it was what
made Amazon so successful.
PayPal started in 1997
or 1998, for instance.
Now you can't survive if
you don't use the internet.
So that's what I'm saying there.
And mobile phones similarly.
By and large, finance, at first,
was providing things online,
or shall I say, on
the internet, but not
necessarily on a mobile app.
And the first mobile apps were
fundamentally just the same
that you could do
online, and then you
had to give a better user
interface, more adaptable,
in essence, something
for the small screen
that our fingers can do easily
and readily on this rather than
on a laptop.
So I'm saying that
today, whether you're
big tech, big
finance, or a startup,
you have to do these things.
You have to do them well or you
can't compete fundamentally.
But maybe I didn't understand
the question, Hassan.
AUDIENCE: I mean, when
you move to cloud,
is it like supporting
the mobile application,
or does it have a different use?
GARY GENSLER: I think it
does a number of things.
Great question.
The cloud, I think,
facilitates greater competition
both as a support function
and also a cost function.
A lot of finance is about trust.
Embedded in finance is
trust, and we give data
to financial firms.
We want that data
to be protected.
Now earlier Dani
raised the underbelly
about how they use the data.
But we want to protect it.
So by using the cloud,
any financial competitor
can better insure
for cyber security.
One of the dominant things about
the cloud is it can lower cost.
It can provide a standardized
form of data security or cyber
security.
And I think it somewhat levels
the field of competition.
But it's a supporting role.
You're right.
It's not something, necessarily,
that's there for the users,
for you and me to see.
But we couldn't
use Credit Karma,
we couldn't use Robin
Hood, we couldn't
use many of the insurance apps
if those venture capitalists
and entrepreneurs behind it had
decided to build their own data
centers.
They wouldn't have
been able to stand up
with the same scalability
and same time frames
at the same costs.
So it's facilitated a tremendous
amount of competition.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARY GENSLER: So sometimes
in infrastructure technology,
I might consider the cloud
an infrastructure technology
rather than a user
facing technology.
But as an infrastructure
technology,
it's darn important.
And so in that context,
I've also sort of said,
well, there's the customer
interface and chat
bots and open API
or what we've been
talking about in this class.
But it all builds on
that which came right
before it, mobile phones, the
internet, as we just said.
And we've dominantly focused
on customer interface and risk
management.
Risk management,
what we've focused
on in this class, machine
learning dominantly, sensors
and telematics in
the insurance field,
peer to peer lending is in
the risk management side.
But all of this
built, and could not
have been built without the
asset-backed securitization.
And like the cloud
earlier, Hassan,
if I can use that, the
cloud is an infrastructure
technology, the technology
of risk management,
that you could take a pool of
mortgages, a pool of credit
card receivables, a
pool of auto loans,
and take those and sell them
into the securities markets,
has facilitated a
number of startups
to say, look, I don't
need to use balance sheet.
I can maybe sell these pool
of receivables and loans
into the marketplace.
I could be more like a
broker, more on the front end,
and give great
customer interface,
and then sell into the market.
So some risk
management tools that
were inventions and new
technologies of the 1970s
to the 1990s allows,
then, this build here.
And so one of the central
themes of this class that I want
you to take away
is not necessarily
how machine learning works, not
necessarily how open API works,
but how new technologies
come along in the past,
and they will in the future--
every five to 15
years there's going
to be some new technology.
We seven billion
humans haven't stopped
coming up with
innovations that are
relevant to the
financial world--
and as they do, think about
how it opens a crack, how
it creates an opportunity.
And if you're at
a big incumbent,
if you're a Bank of
America or Mitsui Bank,
think about how it's going to
create an opportunity not only
for you, but your competitors.
And if you don't act upon that
new technology, somebody will.
There'll be a new Transferwise
or Revolut or a Robin Hood
or Ally Pay that comes along
to use that technology.
And I think they
will be dominantly
in these two areas,
customer interface
and in risk management.
But just like the cloud
there could be also things
that are pure infrastructure.
And the cloud
created opportunity
and moved finance along.
So that's kind of the central
sort of conceptual framework
that I bring to this.
And I think that finance
has a fertile ground.
And the important
opportunities in finance,
digitization of money.
Money is now electronic.
Money itself is but
a social construct.
But we used to think
about it in physical ways.
Before a few decades ago, it was
all really physical paper money
or gold or silver.
But frankly.
We're in the 2020s.
We're living through
this coronavirus crisis.
We will have accentuated that.
There's a wide public
acceptance of new tech.
And each time there's a new
tech, a new way to interface,
though finance is
a world of trust,
we tend to have a lot of
trust in new technology.
Now often it's the
new generation.
It's going to be the Gen
Zs and the Millennials
before it's going to be
folks of my generation.
But there's still a wide
acceptance of new tech.
Look at all of us in
the coronavirus crisis
using Zoom and online.
It's not as good as
being in the classroom.
I have to tell you
this is definitely not
as good as being
in the classroom,
but we're learning how
to use this new tech.
And the interface and
the processing systems
of the legacy incumbents leaves
opportunities for competition.
And of course, we've
talked about data.
I'm pausing, Romain, in
case there are questions.
ROMAIN: Let's give it
a few more seconds.
We have a question from Luke.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
What do you think about
encrypting the tech to money
via blockchain so that
we can kind of see where
the public money is spent, i.e.
Korea is actually trying
to think about doing that.
You mentioned China is
thinking about doing that.
This is more possible in more
of the East Asian countries
versus very, very
high individual rights
countries such as the US where
they might be allergic to it.
GARY GENSLER: So you've
embedded a whole bunch
of parts in there.
But let me just say
blockchain technology has
a positive attribute that
it's a shared public ledger.
On some level, you can make
data on that ledger public.
You can also encrypt it and
make it not necessarily public.
So it depends on
the architecture.
But a blockchain technology
with a shared ledger
is what often is called
tamper resistant.
Tamper resistant,
some people say
immutable, which isn't
quite technically correct.
And so a government, or
even a private sector firm,
could use it to say
that's a record of truth.
That's a record that
is tamper resistant.
I haven't seen any
government doing that yet.
But it certainly can be done.
It's been done more
in the private sector.
You'd still have to
trust in the protocol.
You'd have to trust in whatever
nodes or network maintain
that ledger.
But it's a possibility
going forward.
So who are the
actors in fintech?
Who are the broad actors?
Well, we've talked about them.
Big finance, I like to
quote the Central Bank
governor of Brazil,
who gave me this little
saying where he said, big
finance is like fortresses.
They have moats and towers
and sovereign affiliations.
And I mean, it breaks
down a little bit, too.
But it has some apt
parts of it, being
the towers are big finance
are dominant in payments.
They have their balance sheets.
They, too, collect
data, and they're
vast corporate
structures, often,
of 1,000 to 5,000 legal
entities around the globe.
But there's challenges
to big finance,
particularly in payments,
and some of them
are now even
incumbents themselves
like Pay Pal and Square
and Stripe and the like.
Startups of just 10
and 20 years ago,
now they feel a little bit
like incumbents as well.
But I think big finance, as
we talked earlier with Dani,
I think big finance,
we will still
have banks in 10 and
30 years because there
is network economics
around balance sheets.
Any study of diversification
would tell you
if you have a balance sheet that
has thousands of loans on it
rather than a single loan,
you can lower the risk just
through the diversification of
the underwriting and the risk
allocation.
Also, big finance has data.
But there's challenges
to big finance
for sure from big tech, and
the Bank of International
Settlement talks about big
tech in terms of data networks
and activities.
Now the data is a little
different than big finance
because it includes data
outside of the financial world.
So they get a picture
on all of our activity
in a different way.
Google has Google Chrome, it
has Google Maps, it has Gmail.
It has so many ways
to assess data.
Phone companies like Apple have
a lot of sensor data as well.
That sensor data is currently
being used in insurance.
But will it start to be
used in credit and payment
systems and the like?
And then the startups.
And I don't count
the startups out,
but I think to think about
fintech just about startups
is too narrow, and
it's why I think
of fintech around these
three sets of actors.
But startups,
disruptive innovators,
if you throw up 100 finance
startups or fintech startups,
two to five of them are
just going to break through.
I mean, there's
some odds to this
that some will break through.
And they have
flexibility, and they're
a bit of asymmetric risk takers.
They don't have business
models to support and protect.
And often big finance is
protecting a business model.
Credit cards in the
US are dominated
by seven big companies.
And those seven big companies
that dominate in the US,
they want to protect some
of their profit and revenue
models.
And so that gives an opportunity
for companies like Toast
to get into the
restaurant business.
It's a little harder
for a big actor
to go into those individual
sectors and the like.
They also have a bit
of asymmetric risk
as it relates to
regulation, and this is
what Dani was saying earlier.
It's neither good nor bad.
It's just an observation
that startups often
have a little bit of an
attitude as try it out.
If it breaks some rules
somewhere, clean it up.
Work in good faith with the
regulators and the like.
And because they're
smaller, often
regulators around the
globe have decided
to give a little forbearance.
There's something called
regulatory sandboxes
to promote innovation.
If they were larger, there
would be more systemic
and customer-facing problems.
And then fourthly, there's
the official sector.
And so while finance, tech, and
startups are competing and sort
of trying to provide
better products and better
opportunities and
user interfaces,
the official sector cares
about economic growth,
but they also care about
financial stability.
And sometimes they're a
little bit in conflict.
Also, guarding against illicit
activity, promoting inclusion,
and the tenets of investor
and consumer protection.
So what were the big
technologies we talked about?
And Romain, I'm
going to pause to see
if there are any questions.
Still there?
ROMAIN: Yes.
I don't see any so far.
GARY GENSLER: I just wanted
to make sure my internet
connection didn't go.
So right now in
finance, where we've
seen machine learning,
this extraordinary ability
to extract patterns, extract
correlations out of data.
We've seen it
primarily in the middle
here around fraud detection
and prevention, regulatory,
that a lot of the credit
card companies and big banks
are using it to extract
correlations to better do
fraud protection and better
do what's called any money
laundering and compliance.
So that big bucket
is compliance.
I'd say the second
most developed area
is around natural language
processing or call centers,
chat bots, robo advising.
We all have studied together
robo advising and investments
like around firms like
Betterment and Wealthfront,
I think it's called, and others.
But robo advising, both
in the credit space,
investing space as well.
And Bank of America has their
voice assistant called Erica.
The Siris and Alexas
of finance are going
to be built out in the 2020s.
But I think the most
interesting area,
which is not, frankly,
used that much yet--
it's being used, but not a lot--
is around the underwriting
decisions, underwriting
and insurance,
underwriting in credit.
Basically, how do you
allocate and extend
and price credit or risk?
This is at the core of finance
because the core of finance,
that sort of neck
of the hourglass,
is standing between
savers and borrowers,
or standing between those
who have a risk and those
who are willing to bear a risk.
And as you're at that
neck of the hourglass,
if you can use machine
learning to better allocate
price and extend
credit or insurance,
then you're going to
use that technology.
And extracting patterns is
an important part to do that.
Now you need to do
it within the law you
need to do it within these
questions of fairness
and explainability.
But I think we're going to
see this grow dramatically
by the mid 2020s.
It's already there.
I'm not saying it's not there.
I'm just saying we will
see machine learning used
much more, especially
around alternative data.
We've seen it a bit in asset
management and trading,
but frankly, it's not dominating
the trading floors yet.
It's not dominating
the hedge funds yet.
And a lot of folks
in the hedge fund
community and high
frequency trading community
say that their algorithms,
their linear sort
of type of regressions
and classic statistics,
are doing well enough.
But I think we'll see
this dramatically shift.
And I think at times,
the real question
is, will machine
learning be better
than a classic set of regression
analyses, a classic set
of statistics that you can do?
The answer is if
it's not, you'll
stick with the
classic statistics.
It's not as if you have to throw
away the classic data analysis.
This is just a stronger tool
in certain circumstances
to add on top of it.
Romain, questions?
ROMAIN: Let's give
it a few seconds.
One, two, three.
No questions, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: There
is this debate
sometimes, is artificial
intelligence machine learning
a tool or a Service?
Is it itself an industry or not?
I find myself thinking
more and more,
it's frankly a tool dominantly.
But it is also a
service at times.
It is a tool that is
already being used
and will be used more and
more inside of big finance,
big tech, and disruptors.
But that's not to say it's
not also a service at times.
It can be something
like I'm showing here
as a compliance software.
So you can stand up
a company that does
one of these things going back.
You can stand up a company that
does fraud detection better
than the banks do right
now or stands up something
around credit or insurance,
as a number of startups
have done in the
insurance field that
can take data in, access data.
And maybe you're a data
aggregator from the payment
space like Plaid , or a
data aggregator in insurance
that's taking in all
that telematics data from
automobiles.
And taking that data, you
can use AI as a service.
And some of these, like
anti-fraud softwares
like Featurespace and
others, or Tractable,
which is doing insurance
claims processing,
are doing AI as a service.
I think you'll see, though, that
the dominant way we're going
to be thinking about
AI, really already now,
but within a few
years, it's a tool
that if you don't have
it in your toolkit,
if you don't use machine
learning to do better data
analytics, you're going
to fall behind somewhere,
whether it's in
your compliance side
or whether it's in
your underwriting side.
And others who use
machine learning
will have a more nuanced, more
flexible, and ultimately higher
revenue potential, lower
cost potential underwriting
of insurance or credit.
But I'd think about
it as both ways.
Natural language
processing, a form
of artificial intelligence,
but important slipstream.
It's really about taking human
words and computer language
and doing the interface.
Content generation, content
summarization, and the like.
And so what are we already
using it for in finance?
A lot of ways.
Customer service, those
chat bots and the Ericas
at Bank of America and the
robo advisors and the like.
That's a big piece.
But that's going to continue to
be facilitated and go further,
where one day we'll get on the
phone and we won't quite know,
are we talking to a human or
a chat bot on the other line?
Chat bots right now can't
deal with sarcasm too well.
So you can kind of suss it
out, still, a little bit
with a little bit of sarcasm.
But I don't know, in a number
of years, what it will be.
Basic process
automation, and an area
that asset managers are
using more and more, still
just a little bit,
using more and more,
sentiment analysis, analyzing
vast amount of spoken words,
written words,
and seeing if they
can assess a sentiment
that might be important
investing in the markets.
We spent a fair amount of time
on open API and open banking.
And the critical
thing here is really
access to data and an
ability to build software
on top of platforms.
So in this case, think of
big finance as the platforms,
just like you might think
of Facebook as a platform.
Can you build some
software on top of it?
Maybe it's software to do
one small aspect of finance
better than the big platform is
doing right now, just like you
can build one small application
on top of Facebook and say,
we can do something better.
Now Facebook and other
technology platforms
sought to facilitate
this through open API,
saying developers can build
on top of our platforms.
Big finance was of mixed minds.
Some of big finance
wanted to promote it.
Some didn't.
The official sector stepped
in, particularly in Europe,
with the payment systems
directive and other directives
in the United Kingdom
around open API.
But then around the globe,
Brazil and other countries,
as we talked about,
said no, we've
got to promote some
competition here
and share data, in essence.
The shared data is
permission by us.
That means we say, yes,
you can have my data.
It's sitting there at Bank of
America, but you can have it.
The alternatives--
and this is kind
of an interesting
technological competition--
the alternatives was,
I could permission
an application like
Credit Karma to go
get my data at Bank of America.
And if Bank of America did
not provide an open API
to Credit Karma, or
an open API, possibly,
to Plaid, which is
a data aggregator,
that Plaid then created
data to Credit Karma.
If Bank of America said
now, then maybe Credit Karma
would go and do something
called screen scraping,
literally taking pictures
of screens using technology
to get that data, or
reverse engineering
of a robotic process automation.
So there was a little
bit of a competition
that open API is also a safer,
more secure way to do it,
a more standardized
way to do it.
So what we've seen
is banks kind of--
a little bit disappointing
to their business model--
banks kind of coming into this.
As I said, many banks
thought it was a good idea
to be more like Facebook
and let startups build apps
on top of them.
Some banks said no.
The official sector
got involved.
But also, technological
competition got involved,
this screen scraping and
reverse process automation.
Romain, I'm going to pause.
ROMAIN: Let's see if the
class has any questions.
GARY GENSLER: And I assure
you that more opportunities
hacve been created
around open API
and open banking than we could
ever talk about in a semester.
And it's usually sort of
thought of as a little bit
infrastructure, a
little bit back office.
But there's rarely a central
bank governor around the globe
that isn't talking about
this, thinking about this,
how to promote competition
within their banking sectors
and in their countries.
AUDIENCE: We don't
have any hands up,
so we can continue, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: I mentioned
robotic process automation.
Some of robotic
process automation
is just the startups using
it to compete and get
the data in a closed
or more resilient
system that doesn't
want to give them data.
In some countries, you
can't get it easily
through the market structures
or the official sanctioned open
API.
But it's also being used by
incumbents just to accounts
and onboarding.
It's basically taking
something that humans
were doing and automating it.
And it's called robotic
process automation.
But just think of any process.
It can be reading documents
and onboarding a client.
So how does a big wealth
management company,
how does an online broker or a
mobile broker or online us now,
and that you can literally
just scan the documents.
It reads it, and
voila, we're in,
that we don't have to go to
some bricks and mortar place
and get physical
documents any longer.
So it's an important
piece of competition
in lowering costs, also, and
enhancing user interfaces.
Let me talk a little bit about
credit scores and alternative
data.
The Fair Isaac Company, founded
about 50 to 60 years ago
by a couple of Stanford
graduates named Fair and Isaac,
so thus FICO.
It's used in 32 countries.
There are many countries
that don't use it,
but it is a dominant
way to think
about credit scoring
in the latter part
of the 20th century and
even the early 21st century.
And here's the ratios, that
30% of this and 35% of that.
It's very static.
It's been updated
about eight times.
There's a rollout of a new
FICO score this summer of 2020
as well.
But alternative data might give
us a better picture on somebody
and whether they're going
to default on a loan,
or whether they're the
right insurance risk.
And so the first sort
of rudimentary level
of alternative data
that goes beyond FICO
score is your
employment or income,
or whether you even
paid your rent on time.
FICO score traditionally
hasn't used
even whether you're paying
your utilities or rent
checks on time.
Or, as Ally Pay and
WeChat Pay can do,
look at a small
business and look
at your whole cash flow picture,
your revenues and your costs.
Or here in the US,
Intuit, which Intuit
is a company that has TurboTax
and has more recently bought
some fintech startups
as well, that Intuit
can see the whole cash
flow picture around you.
And so why is Intuit starting
to think about credit?
Because they can get a really
good picture around you.
But there's also
everything we do
online, our consumption and
purchase transactional data.
Think Visa and Mastercard
and what they know about us,
or what our bank knows about our
consumption and purchase data,
using that to say if we buy
one product versus another,
are we a better credit risk
or a lesser credit risk?
In an earlier era,
one of the things
that people would look at, and
this is just a narrow slice,
is whether you replaced
your automobile tires
on a regular basis
with new tires,
or whether you bought retreads,
literally putting rubber
on the old tires.
And it was found that new tire
purchasers on a regular basis
were better credits than
if you bought retreads.
Well, expand that out.
What purchase history
would tell you
that somebody is a little less
or a little bit more capable
to hold a loan going forward?
But app usage, browsing
history, emails, et cetera,
your geolocation.
And in China, we see this being
used in a social credit scoring
system where the
government, in coordination
with many online services,
including Ally Pay and WeChat
Pay, but even extended to
social networking sites
like dating apps.
Literally the dating apps are
feeding in some information
into the social credit
scoring system in China
that then can be used about
extension of credit or not.
And then thirdly, particularly
out of the insurance field
and insurtech.
But my question
is, how will this
be used all the way into
credit extension as well?
Is the information
being collected
through drones and Internet
of Things and sensors
throughout society?
And we're moving
into a world now
where we'll go from
tens of billions
of sensors around
the globe, and that's
the rough measurement now,
to hundreds of billions
of sensors around the globe.
And whether it's in our
refrigerators at home,
whether it's in our automobiles,
whether it's wearables,
whether, frankly, one
day it's in the paint
we paint our houses, literally.
That type of sensor
technology, then
how does it feed back
into, first, in insurance,
our homeowners insurance,
our automobile insurance,
our health insurance
from a wearable,
but how that data analytics
then moves into our credit
scoring as well.
Now all of this has to be done
somehow within social norms
and laws about fairness
and explainability
and guarding against biases.
And those are real
and important issues,
but I think that's
where we're headed
with a lot of this
alternative data.
Questions?
This is sthe stuff Dani gets a
little nervous about, I think.
ROMAIN: Danielle?
GARY GENSLER: I knew I
would spark something.
AUDIENCE: Well, since you asked.
So there is a
international framework
of laws around the right to
privacy from the human rights
space that are
applicable to some
of the emerging ways in which
we're seeing data be collected.
And I'm just curious
your thoughts on
whether you see that ever really
getting traction, particularly
in the US, in terms of impacting
regulations around how data
is collected, how it's used.
I realize it's quite
an open-ended question.
GARY GENSLER: I
think that this is
going to be an
ongoing public policy
debate and cultural debate.
And it's not something
that will settle down
in just two or three years.
I think this is a multi-decade
how we feel about this,
that as sensors,
particularly, will go from 20,
30 billion or so sensors
already00 maybe it's maybe
it's even further than that
now to hundreds of billions
of sensors--
as they become truly
ubiquitous, and cameras
in the homes and
the like, that data
is going to be collected,
analyzed, stored, assessed,
and used in some way to
underwrite insurance and extend
credit.
I think that's the
large cultural trend
and technological and
financial trend we're on.
So then how do we
deal with that?
How do we feel about that,
coupled with all the data
that's being collected
as we are online
in our geolocations
with our cell phones?
So we've seen some jurisdictions
like Europe pass a General Data
Protection Regulation, GDPR.
We've seen in the US it's
more state-based, California.
But even years ago, Illinois
put something in place
around photographs of our
face that are unique to us
and so forth.
So a handful of
states, and so forth.
I think we're going to
keep trying to figure out
what's the right balance.
And even this crisis we're
living through right, now
the coronavirus crisis,
about contact tracing.
If we can save lives,
and we can legitimately
really save lives and
have better health care
outcomes by tracing
our contacts out,
not just who we've seen
in the last two days,
but the last 14 days,
and who they've seen,
and how some countries
like South Korea,
and even Vietnam and
elsewhere, have used
contact tracing to some success.
There's a lot of research
to be done to see
how that's truly playing out.
Will we shift this
debate a little bit?
Will we all say,
look, I'll give up
a little bit of my
civil liberties,
a little bit of my privacy,
for the good of the community
and the good of health
care and so forth.
So I think this is going to play
out for quite some time, Dani.
And I also think technology
can provide solutions,
and some of it can be around
blockchain technology,
where Luke and we were talking
earlier about encryption
you can have data on an
immutable record, really,
a tamper resistant record on
the blockchain technology that
is fully public.
But you can also use
various encryption methods
called zero knowledge proofs
and others to sort of lock it
down and make it harder to see.
And there's great
work on this being
done at MIT by faculty
members like Sandy Pentland
and Silvio Micali and the like.
So I think technology can
help this debate as well.
It might be that we share
things in certain circumstances
and we sort of protected
in other circumstances.
So I'm sorry you're
going to end up being
a little nervous for a while.
I think technology can help us.
But I do think we're going to
be sharing a lot more data.
We talked about
blockchain technology.
The big question,
to me, is adoption
rests on addressing
what's its viability?
What's its comparative
viability and value proposition?
Do we really need
a private currency,
or is the fiat currency
working just fine.
There's been private
currencies for centuries,
and bitcoin has
shown that it can
live for now about a dozen years
as a speculative digital store
of value.
But can other cryptocurrencies
take hold in small ecosystems,
whether it's on gaming
sites, in an industry that's
nearly $175 billion,
$200 billion industry
around the globe,
can it take hold
in online gambling
in a legal way,
not in some of the sketchier,
fraud-oriented ways.
Can private
currencies in gambling
be like casino chips, but again,
in a, hopefully, legal way.
Could it have some
broader applications?
And blockchain technology has
a shared database structure,
a shared ledger.
Can it promote standardization?
Can it promote some
co-opetition where
some infrastructure is
shared, and then companies
compete on top of it, like in
trade finance and elsewhere.
I think school's still out.
We don't know yet,
beyond sort of this thing
that we've already
seen that it's
been a heck of a
catalyst for change.
It is pushing up against big
finance and central banks
to think about
payment systems, I
think, in a more inclusive, more
24 hour a day, seven day a week
way.
I think it's making
payment system
providers, central banks, and
big tech think about new ways
to do cross-border remittances.
And I think Facebook
has both sort
of put some nervousness
in central bankers,
but hopefully also promote them
to do their payment solutions
in a better way for the public.
So it's been a
catalyst for change.
But I think school's still
out about how much mainstream
adoption we'll see.
And the payment system,
we're going to quickly do
some of the sectors.
These were some of the pain
points we talked about.
Who were the players
that we've seen?
Well, big financer players in
every one of these sectors.
I won't repeat this slide, but
never count big finance out.
Most of these companies are
spending multiple billions
of dollars of a year on
their technology budgets.
Most of these
companies that you see
on the screen, the
Bank of Americs,
is the Cap Ones, the Vanguards,
have not hundreds, but maybe
thousands of people in their
data analytics machine learning
side.
And nearly all of them are
using robo advisors or chat bots
by now.
So big finance is incorporating
as much of this technology in,
but they have legacy
business models.
They have legacy tech stacks.
They have legacy approaches.
And so that provides
opportunities for big tech
and startups.
So in the payment space,
we talked about it.
Ally Pay and M-Pesa in Kenya
and Africa, really got in there.
And then Amazon and
Google and so forth.
And in South Korea, Kakao
Pay have really rolled in.
And in certain countries,
like in Africa,
in Asia, big tech fundamentally
dominates the payment space.
Startups got in, often,
around data aggregation,
like Plaid and others, and
open API, but also got in
around sectors like Toast
in the restaurant business.
Or some just did the job a
little better than big finance
and had enough time.
Some got in, also, around
cross-border remittances
like Transferwise and the like.
countries like Brazil and seen
Pax Sikora and PayTM in India.
So it's not isolated
to developed countries.
It's not isolated to Asia.
It's around the globe,
the payment space
has been very dynamic area.
Credit markets.
Credit markets
we've talked about.
The market design has
a lot of features,
and thus a lot of gaps
and a lot of pain points,
whether it's around data,
funding, marketing channels.
I think a lot of what we've
seen in the credit area
has been about enhanced user
experience and user interface,
but then using alternative data.
And on the funding side, trying
to find an issuer bank partner
or securitizing.
By and large, the
startups haven't said,
it's our balance sheet.
That's sort of like a
comparative advantage, for now,
of the big financial firms.
And you could be in any part of
the value chains, all the way
from the brokerage in
origination all the way down
to collecting and foreclosing.
You'd have to pick sort of
where you're going to be.
Competition has been
fierce in big tech.
Not only does Amazon have Amazon
Pay, they have Amazon Lending.
Apple has an Apple
credit card now,
partnering up with Goldman
Sachs and Mastercard.
Keiko Bank on top of Keiko Pay.
And often, the
theory of the case
was build a payment
infrastructure,
get in the payment side, and
then put credit on top of it.
But then there's been a bunch
of startups that have said,
we're not going to
build the payment space.
That's already pretty
darned competitive.
We're just going to come
into the credit side.
And I've just sort of thrown
up the logos of 20 or 25 credit
startups that tend
to be unicorns.
I don't know if they're
still worth over $1 billion
in the middle of
the corona crisis.
But there's a lot of
different models here.
Some are just going straight
at the banking model
like Revolut other neo banks.
Some have come at it from
the credit card space.
Some have done it from
low cost credit reports
like Credit Karma.
So there's a lot
of different angles
to how to break into
the credit space,
all of it fundamentally going
back to some slice of market
design, that if you're looking
at one of these businesses,
if you're thinking about
being employed by one
of these businesses, think
what's their business model?
Is their business
model fundamentally
about a better user experience?
Is it about somehow
doing alternative data
in a way that's different
or better than others?
Is it about one
slice of the rolls?
And they're the
best, and they're
trying to be the best at
the front end brokerage.
We've seen in the mortgage
space, for 20 years now,
this take off, but
particularly post
the 2008 crisis, the
Quicken Loan and Penny Mac
and others now dominate
the front end of mortgages.
Now partly they're able to do
that because our government
here in the US is so
involved with conforming
loan market and Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac,
and what's called the
government-sponsored
enterprises.
And we have a really large,
developed $10 trillion
market, nearly, on
mortgage securitizations.
So you can be Quicken Loan
and be at the front end
and say, just like I might
rent data storage in the cloud,
I'm kind of, in essence,
renting balance sheet
by securitizing the mortgages.
A little tougher in
some other fields,
but you've seen a real takeoff
in the US of the personal loan
marketplace.
I think you can sort of
envision that's going
to keep competing with the
credit card space as well.
We talked about capital markets,
and particularly this move
to zero commissions.
And late in 2019, we saw sort
of the final part of 20-,
one might even say 50-year
history of commissions coming
down and down, starting
with the early 1970s,
when laws were changed
to allow for competition
and commissions.
But it really took
a startup named
Robin Hood to get to
about 10 million users,
a free commission app.
Robin Hood just started
a few years ago,
sort of competing with earlier
fintech startups, earlier
fintech startups like Ameritrade
and E-trade and the like.
And last fall of
2019, zero commission.
But I like this slide,
which is this iceberg.
There's a lot of other
ways to earn revenues,
revenues around selling the
order flow, as Robinhood does,
or earning fees on managing and
custodial side of the balance
sheets for investors.
So I think there's
a competition going
on to what might look like
zero commissions or zero fees,
and then there'll be other
revenue models below it.
We also have seen robo advising.
And Betterment and
Wealthfront and others
have really gotten significantly
into robo advising.
2020, already 50 million,
60 million accounts that
have robo advising in there.
And so the capital markets.
This is the fintech startups.
Remember, Vanguard and
Fidelity are not just
sleeping, or T. Rowe Price.
They are moving into
robo advising as well.
And Robin Hood pushing
to zero fees also
moved Ameritrade and
Vanguard and Fidelity et al
into a more competitive space.
And they're building on top
of another technology called
exchange traded funds,
which was an earlier
era of fintech as well,
these low cost asset
management funds.
We talked about the
asset management side
itself, Acorn, Betterment
and Wealthfront and the like.
These are just some
of the unicorns.
In the capital
market space as well,
we have a bunch of
crypto exchanges.
But it's not just
A few of these companies
are outside of that.
And then insurance.
I know it didn't
light up the class,
but I kind of think insurance
brings so much of this
together.
And I think it's worthwhile
to study insurm tech even
if you're keen interest is
over in credit tech or payment
tech, if I might say, because
what's happening in insurtech
is the opportunities are real.
The user interfaces,
the user experiences
are a little bit, frankly, more
staid and a little bit more
clunkier.
They feel from an earlier time
when you take out an insurance
policy.
The underwriting has a
lot of the same issues.
But also the data, you can
pull from a lot more data,
as we've talked about.
And the current sector,
just like payment sector
has pain points,
the insurance sector
has a lot of challenges
from the fee structures,
between 8% and 15%
of the revenues
go back to the agents
and broker fees,
to the claims administration,
a lot of significant operating
and expenses.
And we hear this debate
around health care policy.
We hear it about, just
how do we sort of take
the costs out of the
system in insurance,
so for every dollar
that you pay in premium,
a higher percentage of that
dollar goes back in claims.
Now we'll always have some
cost of claims management
and agents and
brokers and the like.
But how do we sort of
compress claims management?
How do we compress
the selling so
that a higher
percentage of premiums
ultimately goes to claims?
And so we've seen a
lot of competition
in property and casualty,
health, benefit administration.
More around property
and casualty
because this is around
automobile insurance
and household insurance.
Most of the insurance
startups are
focusing on the retail sector.
But that's also true
in credit products.
Think about where most of the
payment and credit startups,
they're focusing on you and
me and small businesses.
They're not trying to take
away the payment and credit
allocation to Ford
Motor Company.
They're trying to help
us, help the broad public,
with a better user interface
and a better product offering.
And in this area,
these auto insurers
like Root Insurance
can actually give us
insurance based
upon the telematics
and how we're
driving in that car.
Now that might square
Dani a little bit,
that they know exactly
where you're driving
and how you're driving
and whether you
put your foot on your
brake too often or not
in their data analytics model.
I'm not trying to
judge how often Dani
puts your foot on the brake.
But in their data analytics
model, they might think so.
Or in India, Policy Bazaar
that really is kind of
like the Expedia of insurance
in India, where you can
compare and contrast insurance.
There's a lot of
exciting things.
Here I am going
again, trying to get
you excited about insurtech.
But I would study
insurtech to say, OK,
what can I learn
from it, to move back
to the rest of
fintech, what I might
call credit tech or investech
or payment tech, if you wish,
because I think a lot
that's going on here
will influence back.
Or you might say it's
already happened.
Some of what's happening,
insurance tech,
is a little later, but has
already happened elsewhere.
We closed out this semester
because we've lived
it, the coronavirus crisis.
And I think the
coronavirus crisis,
beyond all these
huge challenges we
have from a health care
and economic point of view,
just putting it
back in the context
of financial technology.
I think startups are
going to have to focus,
and are already focusing
on what we call runway,
their burn rates, their cash,
their revenue, their adoption
and so forth.
Initial public offerings
are on hold in 2020,
probably well into 2021.
Venture capital
investment's already slowed
and will continue to slow,
and valuations, thus, just
inevitably need to decline
in this environment.
And consolidation is
likely to increase.
There's clearly going to
be winners and losers.
I'm not saying anything
terribly important there.
But the sectors matter.
Some sectors related
to compliance,
that might be pretty good.
But if you're a sector related
to travel or entertainment
or restaurants,
probably pretty bad.
So beyond the sectors,
it's really back to runway.
Now there are
opportunities serving
the various fiscal stimulus
and loan programs in Europe,
the US, Asia, elsewhere.
I think the challenges are going
to mount in the next six to 18
months around delinquencies.
We haven't seen this hit hard
yet in the household sector.
But it's inevitable, as
this crisis moves forward,
that the household
sector is going to have
to repair their balance sheets.
And frankly, too,
many people will
have to declare bankruptcy or
be in default or delinquency.
The small business sector
that a lot of fintech startups
supported will have to either
repair their balance sheets
or go into delinquency and
default. So a lot of challenges
around the startup deal.
But I say this from my
time at Goldman Sachs.
Challenging times also present
opportunities for all of us,
for you as individuals,
and for these companies.
I want to close on something
that Ben Franklin said
long ago about money, and
it's about paying it forward.
"I do not pretend
to give such a deed.
I only lend it.
When you meet with another
honest man in similar distress,
you must pay me by lending
this sum to him or her,
enjoining her to discharge
the debt by a like operation
when she shall be able and shall
meet with another opportunity."
This is Benjamin
Franklin on money.
I would say it was fintech
of the 1770s to 1790s.
"I hope it may us go
through many hands
before it meets with a nave"--
nave is an old English word
to say fool--
"meet with a nave that
will stop its progress.
This is a trick of mine
of doing a deal of good
with a little money."
So take this little homage,
this little sang of Benjamin
Franklin, late 18th century.
I call it fintech.
And I ask you just
to do a little good,
not just because we're in
these coronavirus times.
But I've so enjoyed
being with the 80 or so
of you these last 12 sessions.
Do me the favor, six months
from now, 12 months from now,
write me.
Tell me where you are.
Tell me you're
just safe and well.
If you're graduating, tell
me that you got a job.
If you didn't get a
job, ask career advice.
If you're working in
the fintech space,
tell me what you're doing
in the fintech space.
I'd love to learn.
I've learned so much
being your faculty member.